it has been a very eventful few weeks
for division fans with the three stages
of pts wrapping up the sudden
announcement of title update 15 being
released on the 12th of may and a state
of the game stream led by creative
director yannick and community developer
daria
in this video i'm going to cover what
was discussed on stream and what we have
to expect in this new update including
the new story direction
[Music]
[Music]
they were quick to reaffirm would have
been stated quite a while ago where
title update 12 was initially meant to
be the last update to the game but due
to good interaction it was decided that
more content was to be added however
this didn't mean that they could just
jump back in as normal the vast majority
of the original team had been moved on
to new projects so a lot of time was
placed on reassembling a team and
setting up a new development process
title update 15 isn't necessarily the
outcome of the last 12 months worth of
work but rather a small piece of the
long-term support with more seasons and
content to come
the pts was just one of the many ways of
which they have started to reinstate
their communication with the community
it was a good way to get the
conversation going and get an
understanding of the hopes and dreams
the community had in mind
overall the pts has been considered a
success with around 19 000 players
participating
there has been a lot of feedback
including the countdown mode and the
expertise system
as a quick recap countdown is the new
game mode where eight division agents
work together to restore stability to a
power plant that is infested with
enemies and other hazards you have just
15 minutes to prevent a lockdown
deployed in teams of four at different
locations you will need to complete a
series of objectives and then extract
before the time runs out
although it is intended for eight
players it can be completed with less
and there is matchmaking
running through the feedback received a
number of the changes had already been
made by the end of the pts but they are
still looking into the difficulty
options and how this could be scaled for
more experienced teams
for now they are happy with how it is
but will continue to take feedback once
it launches to the rest of the player
base
also discussed with the expertise system
this is a new way to upgrade items
players can build their expertise by
using any item in the game as they use
items they'll become more proficient
with them
once they've maxed out their proficiency
rank with any item type they'll be able
to upgrade its base stats
basically it's a new way for players to
increase their power
the majority of the feedback from the
pts was that it takes too long or costs
too many materials to upgrade items
while the costs have been significantly
reduced the expertise system wasn't
intended to be another activity that
players can power level through as they
stated on the stream this is to be more
of a passive activity much like the
watch
it's more of a slow burn in the
background while working on other things
those in the community screaming out
that it's too slow seem to have missed
the point however the question around
why we need to increase our power level
when the current difficulty is staying
as is is something that still hasn't
been answered
in the stream they also told us of
upcoming season hidden alliance this
will feature a new main target captain
lewis as well as two new apparel events
new reward track and an addition to the
story
following the death of antoine ridgeway
a new leader has risen to take control
they've also set larger goals of moving
their operation nationwide
one leader known as captain lewis has
descended upon washington dc with a
mission of his own
accompanying lewis will be a number of
lieutenants
castillo a civilian turned true son he
has a background in engineering and is
taking over radio frequencies where he
sends out his rants that are being used
as a recruiting tool
daniels this woman is on a rampage and
is assassinating civilians in the
streets
chang a logistical nightmare that has
been so effective in rebuilding supply
chains for the true sons that has become
a major problem
and xander who has been randomly
torturing and interrogating civilians it
is not known what she is actually
looking to find but she has to be
stopped
in their words the new lieutenants and
prime target himself range from
monstrous to sympathetic the ideology
and tactics of the true sons have
changed which in turn starts to alienate
some of their most zealous members while
attracting a new wave of cruel
opportunists with an eye to join an
oppressive army of the powerful
the internal struggles of this new
generation of true sons will shine a
light on the complexities of the world
in turmoil and will provide the first
glance at a new threat rising to
prominence
i'm liking the sounds of this it's like
we'll be seeing a more gritty story
behind the true suns and the state of
the world around them rather than the
straight good versus evil storyline
we've had with a few of the targets up
until now
it looks like we'll be getting a bit of
depth on the inner workings and
complications with the characters and
the true suns organization as well as
what's happening around them
could almost say it feels similar to
some of the stories we were getting in
the original game
although season 9 will be a direct
continuation of where we left off they
use the opportunity to clarify one thing
that feylau is indeed dead
however the consequences of what faye
did will be cleared up
questions like why did she go rogue why
did she kill the president and then
blame the division these will be
answered
they've also stated that the way the
story will be told will be taking a
change in direction
the core message and plot of the
division will no longer be locked behind
a number of collectibles that need to be
pieced together in order to understand
what is going on
hidden alliance will open with a
cinematic showing the outcome following
the confrontation with fey lau at camp
white oak
the story then shifts over kalso benitez
and rhodes who are all coping with what
has happened in their own ways
the addition of cinematic language will
make the stakes in motivation crystal
clear and moved out of the darkness
this new approach has been taken to show
the changing motivation and feelings of
core characters
collectibles will still be available but
these will be easier to obtain by
meeting with kelso at the base of
operations after each manhunt target has
been eliminated
the idea is that this more focused
delivery will help players avoid missing
critical story details
while i find this interesting i just
hope we don't lose everything that the
collectibles gave
i completely agree the majority of
players would like a clear and upfront
story most of these don't want every
detail just the basics the reason for
the collectibles in a lot of games
destiny 2 for example is to provide the
extra detail behind the story and
building of the world without annoying
the players who don't care for it
i'll admit i'm skeptical of this change
but i'm happy for them to be trying
something new as long as we don't lose
any detail
the manhunt structure has also been
tweaked to provide a stronger narrative
rather than exploring every district of
washington the focus will be placed on a
much smaller area giving the opportunity
to provide more contained concentrated
stories and to avoid repetition from
season to season
there has been more flexibility and
variety added to the manhunts too
manhunt lieutenants will each take over
a main mission from the dc campaign
these mission takeovers will become more
common in future seasons as they expand
the capabilities of the system
for now cedar's mission is being
repopulated with true sons who have
taken control for their own purposes
and it goes without saying that we'll be
seeing new weapons and gear including a
heartbreaker gear set new exotic and
named weapons and more
a while ago we were introduced to an
intelligence annex that discussed major
changes to the specialization system
they understand that these aren't really
working as well as they could be most
people just picked the specialization
based on the buffs they were after and
then forget about them
they've been working on a revamp that
would have more meaningful choices to be
made to have a larger impact on your
playstyle to have you make choices that
force you to gain in something but miss
out on another
so this revamp had always been planned
for release with the title 15 update but
they have decided to push it back into a
later update they aren't quite ready
at the end of the stream they took
questions from the community now there
are a whole bunch of them so i've only
summarized the ones that i've also
received a number of questions about
over the last 12 months
when will we have crossplay this is not
something they are looking into at the
moment essentially the way each system
has been set up with separate databases
per platform there is no simple way for
them to flip a switch and have them all
communicate with each other in order for
them to get cross-play working they
would need to dedicate a large team to
have this work within any reasonable
time and currently the team is working
on new content
game crashes in the game the pts crashes
have been fixed and addressed as for the
live crashes they plan on addressing
these in the next update
will there be another dlc there are no
plans to add paid dlcs they plan to
continue with the season and season pass
model as they have been since warlords
of new york
will there be focus on pvp they
understand there is a passionate pvp
community out there but the current team
they have is specialized in pve content
they don't want to give up on pvp since
it's a big part of the game but at the
moment there is no pvp 2.0 patch planned
but they will be keeping an eye on the
big issues and try to address them one
step at a time
will you add more map locations
countdown is essentially a new map
location
map expansions like warlords of new york
are not in the plan at the moment but
there are new maps and new spaces that
you can discover through different types
of content that will be coming out
will there be more legendary missions
the expertise in specialization revamp
will make players more powerful raids
and legendary missions are currently the
most difficult content
adding more legendary missions could be
an option but adding legendary
difficulty to new content is not like
flipping a switch it is handcrafted and
balanced by the developers
the real question is how do you make the
game challenging and interesting for the
players and that needs to be answered
smartly
will you consolidate the dark zones
there are no plans to merge the dark
zones but they are looking into general
topics on how to improve the dark zone
summing up on the 12th of may we'll be
receiving the following a new game mode
called countdown a new leveling system
called expertise manhunt hidden alliance
featuring an alternative way of telling
the story and running through the
targets a new season reward track new
items including weapons gear exotics
named items and gear set
but like i've said before the one piece
i'd like everyone to take away from this
probably the most important piece is
that this is just one of many updates
that we'll be receiving through 2022
there is more to come
beyond that who knows as yannick said
himself during the stream it all depends
on what sort of engagement the game gets
over the next year that will determine
what sort of support will be thrown
their way in the future
anyway thank you very much for watching
not long until the update releases now
so see you in dc
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheers okay